receiving your content a door within
Australia okay Agra such morbidity
loading you are live look at this look
at this drop drawing viewers it's just
insane stuff
are the other websites working properly
yeah oh there oh nice what people are
saying is it works so it's it's back
online I think we are since it says that
you are we are live for 40 yeah it does
say we're alive but hmm okay there also
comes and going there in the chat no no
we we do have internet I just don't I
just don't know if if we are actually
live on YouTube yeah it's bound to
happen at one point I mean we haven't
had a an issue in any of the streams but
now I think everything is working
properly we do receive some okay just in
case in case you were able to re-enter
the chat you know do give us unnoticed
saying that everything is working
properly now dodo
yeah dodo dodo demand
all right we're back yes we are back
okay so we're back we're back when we
see a little bit of a rise here ah let
me just refresh this just in case you
know yeah see see see what's what and
then we are gonna okay I think we're
back now okay we're definitely sorry
about that
no idea why that happens but we do have
we've reached the end of the tournament
yeah and we do have the top yeah
GM Rebecca Harris so Daniel narrow discs
it takes the tournament with first place
grabbing $1,000 then we have night king
I believe Alexander botanique in second
place and in third place ali reza
farrell it as i said that he he he was
in the lead and he lost the lead because
well he obviously he wants some points
against the cheater and the cheater was
banned from the tournament and then he
lost the points he he won against that
guy so maybe i don't know i mean that
that has been like the thing so far as
far as i remember that maybe elite just
should take notice about this here's a
but how do you how do you fix it i mean
that's also i mean yes they do have a
way of fixing it this why they have to
eat just titled arena so you have to be
a title player to enter but it's just I
don't know how to do it without without
you know only only having to get four
title players but yeah yeah cosmic
energy that's that's the thing what's
let's blame it sit there yeah okay the
the titled arena was postponed a bit but
yeah a pity for all the res about still
okay third place and he he died I think
he will continue playing in the elitist
titled arena but yeah so early resin in
third place penguin in fourth then
Nicolai
I believe it's Nikolai people said in
the chart it was Nicole I should I have
in fifth Passos in sixth we have freedom
master vs 99 in seventh mod pro in 8th
international master then in nineteen
leverage that is there is
that's a lot of games not again and
Alexandra Zubov Grand Master Cassandra
Zubov intent and 5732 people have joined
which is less than the previous
tournament but we you know with all the
crazy stuff that happened I I think that
we've done we've done a decent job since
we started I think with 2,000 people at
the beginning when the tournament was
recreated yeah instead of 5,000 you know
it was it was a decent tournament so for
those of you that one I doubt that
you're actually watching the stream but
you should just contact me really chess
and the prizes will be distributed to
you as soon as you contact me so that
being said I will just take a break five
minutes and you can play a few more
games then we're gonna switch then I'm
gonna go to the nice chair and then I'm
good yeah I mean it's not that this
chair isn't nice I know he's just that I
always use this one oh it is a good
chair so play a few games and yes but
only non rated games yeah all rated
games yeah am I allowed to shred playing
another tab yeah play another time I'm
gonna use this one and of course for
when I publish the winners on you know
Twitter Facebook wherever always feel
free to congratulate the winners it's
always the nice thing to do I will
definitely take this opportunity as
since I am a tournament director to
congratulate all the people that were
participating and of course the winners
it is it was very nice tournament sorry
for the technical difficulties but yeah
and sometimes you cannot really be right
back
yeah sure sometimes you cannot foresee
those situations so let's just go back
to these games let's just show a little
bit of my chest knowledge and just try
not to embarrass myself too much which
would be for here and should even look
at the chat because these messages are
going faster and faster by the second
account really track all the things that
are happening
Bishop d2 okay Knight c3 yeah let's just
go let's just force it
we'll just throw everything in am I look
am i left-handed what such a weird
question I indeed I am indeed I am okay
we do have a nice position does it make
sense to capture here on e5 yes Bob
Marley I will definitely take that
advice I will play one minute games
because it is indeed much more
interesting it doesn't make for a long
wait and we can just play through and
play with as many people as possible now
okay Bishop c4 now let's play you for
let just push it through what is my
rating to be honest I don't I don't
really know
I see the the mod is doing his job okay
meeting rush long time no see okay now I
I think I do have a nice position I'm
probably there should be three then a
ninety four jump in there with the night
hmm
let's capture here capture here okay
the tournament winners were announced
just a while back and it's as far as I
know Rebecca Harris won quite a good
tournament it was okay all in all quite
well yeah honestly I really don't know
it was it is around 2150 my rating so if
that's good I guess yay if not never
mind
well I know off Leon I do not know him
personally I hear he's a good guy
he is a good chess player as far as we
have seen so he has that going for him
okay does just defend here on e4 it's
quite hard to focus on the chat and on
the games at the same time but let's
just try to do it
95 seems like a move try to break
through there as well maybe I'll just
one win on time
okay everybody five capture the pawn on
C 2 D 3 oh okay
sorry I almost thought he can capture on
D 3 and capture here Queen D 5 if you
move the bishop captures on d1 am i
winning this game capture capture
capture beautiful are we really playing
this game okay that's all fine captain
oh no I meant to play here but okay that
was nice five checkmate
beautiful so let's take another
challenge it would be a quicker game
this time because let's just play as
many people as possible casual games so
not rated games the first guy that I see
is an ism or something like that so good
game sir okay so we have the pierce
defense the only way how I know to play
it is like this oh he five maybe D 594
no let's play three and h4 c5 or c6 you
know okay
let's capture capture bishop will come
to 86 at some point and now rooks have
said maybe I should have played in two
meet let's play a check here okay let's
move the knight in 93g 597 probably oh
nice
there should be six oh he can go to f8
now it's captured here if he captures in
95 95 interesting let's sacrifice
something never know what will happen
Oh Quinn g5 that looks so good
g6 double of the rooks first ninety five
twenty eight is seven Oh how's it going
look who showed up well I'm just trying
to keep keep up with it yeah okay no
okay that's a free piece are you you
know watching so it's not a another
rated game only casual games yes I am
more eleven are no games
yes there you go very nice now I have
some help okay very a lot of requests
well I know just choose choose choose
wisely I'm gonna go for bullet games
because as I said it gives me a chance
to go and play with more people yeah I
don't know why Lisa still doesn't have
an option where you just applied to
challenge a streamer and then you is
just chronologically so you don't have
to like choose who are playing against
it would be much much yeah cleaner yeah
some sorting would be nice oh gee I'm
already nice okay I'm just gonna leave
it at here howdy for Oh could be
possible
okay so it's 824 we're gonna play a few
games against the treiber's then we're
gonna do the giveaway so we get rid of
that and after we do the giveaway then
we're gonna play some more games we have
some more people here you also is here
Yas oh come say hi okay alright it's a
30-second delay so yeah but you guys
didn't wait for it fist bump this is my
son oh yeah another chess player I'm a
fight you have to give fire yeah okay
they're just for luck
thanks now I have there there is no
other thing I just must win this game
yeah it is actually it is said that five
points he lost due to them you know
getting rid of the cheater
tilted him for the rest of the piled
arena oh you're you're down to two
seconds beautiful okay let's see those
three moves
let's see those know what's that what's
Queens you for what's Queen ji for what
it's something pretty more free yes you
can you can do it now just free move
with the Queen free move like the
penguin no good job don't have don't cry
baby don't cry after this game yeah we
don't know who was who the cheater was
yeah that's always difficult to tell
they just dismiss him and don't really
say much about it yeah yeah I can't tell
you what target matter means if I told
you what target matter means I meant
well we wouldn't have anything to you
know save for for for next milestones
you know this is an interesting game
this one aha Bruno is here yeah he was
indeed the
next one with the casual bullet so yeah
I think yeah Bruno is the very strong in
bulla I think it was over 2500 at one
point really mm-hmm I was never know
it's a busy busy
bullet player young what is the secret
of your beauty people want to know I
don't know plenty of hiking I just have
mother nature okay I guess it is mother
nature do connected pass bonds there
they go
no actually after that I'm only kidding
yeah of course
now okay they did I'm just seeing how
you can you know respond and play bullet
at the same time against Bruno oh that's
that's a difficult task how many girls
are watching well I would say around
five maybe ten on this dream yeah that
could be if we take yeah if we take a
percentage like huh sixteen like yeah if
we take the percentage of my channel it
should be should be around fifty at at
this point but you know you never know
yes 1 million subs and I tell you what
Argan matter means it's very very
secretive it's not very smart it's just
you know as long as I postpone revealing
or revealing it the more mysterious it
seems
Thank You mr. zadir thank you oh no no
man
what okay now you're not too slow Bruno
is a very strong player you can see that
he has six to two against me
okay now seven to do but that does it
he's a very fast does that mean that
he's a strong player yes of course
okay I think yeah I think the - I want
were in hyper bullet the rest were
bullets all right man yeah he is right
why don't we drink the Nam beer yeah
okay let me play a few oh yeah sure I
need to take the rest go to the bed
chair good chair oh yes does it feel
like a better chair well I don't know if
it's a better chair but the screen seems
very far away you know so yeah maybe
that also takes fright okay now I will
mock you Bruno asked why are you not
enjoying your beer yeah that's what I
said yeah I think it's time to do that
alright well it's okay to get warmed up
let's go for ice - Plusle against mr.
Peter yeah sorry about that
it was rough okay we have is it Chopra
yeah yeah what was the name okay okay
let's go for for an I Scandinavian for a
change yeah okay let's see won the
tournament Rebecca Harris yeah Rebecca
Harris and uh after I finish the stream
we're gonna go over the who one who
contacted me who would like to collect
their prize you know the usual and then
of course after I publish all the
winners of course congratulate everyone
it's Luca
hello guys sharpener hey Luca just okay
I'm just gonna say quick hi to my friend
me to rush meeting Rogers here I've seen
a lot of why did why did he delete
because he his
I've been sending it for ah he was
sweating okay okay I've seen you sorry
but yeah you have been noticed yeah it's
very far away to look at the board from
from here yeah it's not you see okay
yeah that's not gonna fly I'm just gonna
leave you for a second yeah sure a
refill if you do you need no I'm good
I'm good okay where are we from
we are from Croatia man okay let's uh
let's get rid of the light square bishop
not really doing all that much for the
moment what's wrong
no it's not any kind of acronym okay
let's go here huh okay that's fair I
guess that's fair how many videos they
took it to cross first 100,000
subscribers I have no idea he wants to
push me five here yeah I want to push e5
here as well yeah definitely definitely
so let's see okay we have to move here
how the Queen's still alive at 10:16
yeah well I blinked I'm gonna try and do
something about it it's okay he opened
up the file for my rook
i I do enjoy that much more than I
thought I'd be getting okay let's just
go all the way now we can open up the
position so everyone is playing with me
though okay see what what's happening
here let's capture with the Queen now
there's the main patient
so how do we meet the is rook rook mate
yeah but it's not my move to make okay
let's just go here next he's gonna move
the King probably starts running away
maybe nope that's how he wants to do it
okay I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
pretend I have more time and it's not a
profit for ya he's overthinking this
yeah he really could not overthink this
she's gonna trap your queen no he's not
okay let's get get a rook in there yet
get more rooks in there let's let's do
this this is good let's do this how do I
get the bishop in I don't okay okay okay
ah it's not the cleanest cleanest the
wind but you know I'll take it I guess
let's see okay let's uh let's see one
from the top when there's gonna be a
next Tiger when we when we finish our
vote on the next saga okay what do we
have
okay a three plus so 2 plus so okay the
bullet Bobo
okay Bobo fishing with an ice bullet
challenge all right Bobo let's do it
Bobo and they say your sorrow has grown
his hair alright let's let's do this
all right well c3 not really a useful
move here but Oh Philip hello everyone
greetings Philip okay I'm just gonna
play this one more than you'reyou're
gonna try and play against Philip okay
let's take this one it's a bullet game
we are up against the bow bow fishing
see see what bow bow
I have a nice beer alright let's go
what's good to hear
okay now we don't let's go here we're
gonna push g4 as well no we don't let's
go here I guess that's a bad Bishop
that's terrible bishop okay we'll grab
this guy here he's gonna belong but how
do we free the bishop we need to free
the bishop and that's it let's block
with the rook you can play Bishop
retreat yeah you cannot tell me what to
play it's cheating you know but but what
I can play is this there that's a move
okay what that's a move okay that's I'm
gonna actually grab this guy here yeah I
did not think this through but okay some
other problems it's not a problem it's
actually pretty bad let's get the other
guy in as well how did I get into this
no he's gonna give it up yes I know he
will check-check
yeah very good mr. Bogle fishing yeah I
totally missed the Queen there no not
rematch not rematch okay
sorry not rematch not rematch there are
no rematches okay let me just try a
different one that was a that was a
there was a poor poor move okay here's a
mr. casual what about your wine I don't
I don't never had any wine in the
streams
okay well we said that we were gonna
have a have a few games so let's have
this one without losing our queen for
nothing
yeah is big yeah it's not beer it's not
beer
yeah buh-buh-buh-buh the legend okay
okay do we put user in timeout yeah
that's what we're gonna do are gonna
need the beer yes thank you mr. bubar
that is that is true all right yeah and
not beer with a short I okay that's
that's interesting and you yeah all
right it requires less less calculating
than not taking it okay three points I
have to connect at once here so
shouldn't be a problem unless he traps
my queen if he traps my queen
we'll take it from there okay let's just
get some more more pieces in there okay
it's interesting it's very interesting
if I grab the night I have 97 okay
now we're threatening to pick up the d5
pawn those are some nice bishops there
but I don't think they'll be up okay
that's uh we're just gonna trade
everything now so ah yeah I should have
captured with the night that's true that
is true but it's also good huh
yeah could have done that better yeah I
should I should indeed but I also want
to activate the pawns and I should I
should activate them faster
well let's activate them nope okay one
rook activated yeah okay you can have
that pawn okay point under attack
let's do something about that huh
yeah that's that loose looks alright if
he doesn't attack my queen which I'm
sure he will
yeah okay he will I know he will now we
push
I guess if captures captures we push the
a pawn yeah you can have that pawn it's
not a problem
oh that's meat Wow
okay oh so he missed it he missed the
meat wow that's that's bad that is bad
Wow
alright wow that was that was really bad
okay that's a bishop this is the
ultimate game okay so you take it from
here okay even though I want I didn't
really win yes you didn't okay let's see
which Philip how many beer do you have
okay if you've had zero beer so the same
as me yeah I'm not on Naruto fine fan
but I know plenty of people that are
it's not like I don't enjoy it it's just
that I'm not like a big fan just take
care you only accept casual games no no
radio games yeah I had like three
numbers yeah that's that's a decent
amount of amount of others Philip what's
your rating around 2000 he's around 2000
although unleashes you are over 2100
yeah below a below okay
but you were above at one point yes okay
I fell down but he finished what was
your place on this tournament today I
was in the top 200 like 170 168
somewhere right Oh Fran your average
fellow from health to going on our field
doesn't need luck
look at those pre moves Eva do Dupree
move evil sometimes okay okay we're a
bit blurry now so perhaps someone is
hogging our bandwidth but we'll see set
okay set hands and we'll definitely do a
shot maybe before the giveaway so the
giveaway will do the giveaway in some 18
minutes huh
Abraham hey man just just don't spam it
out someone who wishes Phillip good luck
in the tournament tomorrow do you have a
tournament tomorrow yes I'm playing on
the second board okay someone someone
who wishes you good luck for your
tournament tomorrow okay what do we have
here I'm feeling or is it Oh awesome
yes tactics that don't work okay but you
still have you still have a rock in the
night you know make it work maybe a
eight maybe not see it yeah mission
fails
okay
ha okay but now it's now it's
challenging so it's okay no Roxy - for
you not to do AHA so okay it would have
been better country
okay what what's that
quick okay okay it's the first game yeah
sure
just pick pick someone with two plus or
maybe yeah we accept as many challenges
as possible so maybe challenge to two
plus oneth three plus all or a 5 plus
all so we get as many as many people as
possible it says that the stream is
healthy again so try and try and update
your well your quality of the stream I
think you can actually you can get it in
high definition it shouldn't be a
problem
towel versus Coblentz
to be better than Jurgen it's a versus
tal I don't know granita vs. tall that's
one of my all-time favorites and the
complaint was tall Tudor so I don't know
maybe maybe maybe complaints you know
but also a very strong attacker so it's
hard to say hyper bullet challenge yeah
hyperbolic is the best but I don't know
if my bandwidth can take it it's it's a
lot to take
okay yeah no I do not speak Russian I do
I do understand it mostly when when I
hear it in movies but I you know I I do
not I'm not able to form words and good
to know good to know mr. goat and the
wolf yeah okay you could argue that
anything under one plus aw isn't really
good but you know it's a very how to put
it it's refreshing it's it's fun you
know if the point is to have fun then
then I guess it's it alright
yes ROP I thought of did you improve
your English people are asking no I
still have resonates very strong no no
can we hold an under 2000 tournament
will also also an idea but then a lot of
people wouldn't be able to join I guess
yeah and and those who are rate high
written in 2008 they'll just make you
know new accounts so I don't think we'll
actually be achieving anything thanks
man
Philip how old are you I am a 13 years
old
okay there you have it almost 14 same as
same as Bobby Fischer
I don't ladies game of the century
Rafi's my very cool stupid guy so what's
on my three what what is this what
Thanks yeah what okay it's not it's not
helping is just that's a hanging Queen
do you have those 500 K shirts for sale
no these are one-of-a-kind we'll maybe
maybe maybe four of a kind but but still
those are the only we have always blank
maybe you accept challenges where people
say they wanna play as white so maybe
that could also be be the case
ah 15 plus 15 I think that'd be a bit
too much for a for a stream are we close
to split no we are on the on the
opposite side of Croatia yeah yeah only
casual games yeah three three plus so of
course it's it's much better but to pass
away we get much more games in
thank you Thank You mr. Harris for for
keeping the the chat clean very nicely
done
don't overuse your power you know yes I
I made in my mode so we only have one
mode for now but you know with with
great power comes great responsibility
so give me the phone just the show
meadow since everyone's asking where is
meadow okay here is meadow yeah you
wanted to know where he is so there is
the greedy bastard look at him sleep
there you have it I don't know if I'm
actually doing this right but yeah okay
sorry the battery's low on yellowness
phone so I did not know that okay that's
a that's a nice looking rook if you pre
move that I don't think there's a move
he could play that actually wins okay
there is like if he plays Queen III you
grab the rookie wins the Queen but other
than that yeah that's just weird
yeah that's a that's a blank screen no I
do not I I don't watch a lot of football
like if there's like a really important
game I don't know maybe if if Croatia is
playing against someone then I might
watch it but it's very very rarely yeah
okay I do I will watch a World Cup or
the world yeah almost the World Chess
Championship or the World Championship
but other than that very rarely could I
explain ideas behind the moves in my
videos well I I might be able to but I
don't think I'd be doing a very good job
at it I think there are much more
capable people of doing that and who are
actually doing that okay can i play
blind chess I can but not well but then
again I can play regular chess what's
all that I guess the answer is yes no
these are not my children these are
Gordon's children yeah I don't know if
we can actually use music since you know
yeah even though it's a stream I don't
know I don't know what I mean I have
used some music in my one of my first
streams or maybe two of my first streams
and there weren't any problems but I
don't know it's just yeah it's just I
don't know I preferred without music
actually I prefer watching channels
stream without music so I I guess that's
why I do without music favorite creation
word what's your favorite creation word
shop
that's not oppression words doing what I
don't know
Nakia that's a nice word I don't drink
it you don't have to drink it the
question is what's a nice word favorite
subscriber I don't think I have a
favorite subscriber do do i watch MMA
well I don't watch it like religiously
you know or follow it but if I some you
know if I see it on Twitter Wow there
was a really awesome match then I will I
will check it out maybe not the whole
match but maybe the highlights but I
guess everyone does that you guys watch
MMA mixed martial arts
yeah okay I guess well I will try to
show more of my game so you have some
older games which are really really
crazy crazy bad but still you know we
can we can learn a lot from them
thank you mr. Carlos and thank you for
the Congrats
yeah metro cop there there's a beast for
you
mode I feel sorry for you yeah
what has a lot a lot on his shoulders
but you know those are you know there
are certain people that can be mods and
there are people that can't be mod if
you're meant to be a mod you know you
just do a good job and that's how it is
okay we're still you're still completely
winning so I guess no problem
okay evil you take one okay now it's it
was turned evil the Beast let me just
refresh this we refresh this so we get
no no we get better quality if we
refresh it or so so I think okay will
you choose the opponent okay which one
hated known only casual I think people
are so far challenging only in casual
yeah meadow the faithful guard dog
Oh II was playing if you want the
challenge to just challenge my account
we're all using my accounts I don't know
if I say this quite enough but we are
playing non rated games so everyone can
use this account it's not a problem yeah
that's that's made of arcing that's an
idle evil the the sneaky neither player
how old is evil you older evil is 11
yeah Pirates of the Caribbean do you
like it well I like the theme song not
too crazy about the movie thank you
mister I you make a tutorial how to make
a girlfriend what yeah I don't think if
you need such a tutorial I don't think
it will help you all that much or maybe
I misread it why don't we hear anything
about alpha 0 alpha zero is busy busy
now he's playing Starcraft and you know
doing some important whoa I don't know
I've heard that the moment offer 0 is
like in that top 1% of the of the
Starcraft community I could be wrong I'm
not a soccer player myself but something
you know along those lines make more
videos on opening preparation how can I
make more videos on opening preparation
if I don't have any videos on opening
preparation yeah although I did play
Starcraft 1 quite a lot but but not sir
Starcraft 2
I follow the MBA it's great
I'll I can be they still have to wake up
like in 4:00 a.m. in the morning to
watch games no I don't watch it life I
watched aha you watch replays okay with
you because I know my friends he he was
watching them line and he had to wake up
like it 4:00 a.m. I watch him no it
doesn't make sense to wake up just for a
name being gay but yeah work to what
sure like Formula One yeah I don't like
Formula One I like sports with me yeah
Magnus is online in on Twitter
yeah let's challenge him okay maybe he
drops a challenge who knows is he online
Evo would you play against Magnus if you
could we'll check if he's online did I
watch that no yes I have seen that noted
so it's quite quite enjoyable even 13
seconds that's enough for you to take
him okay
yes check and nothing and pre-move check
and free move oh yes check me going you
have to pre move you have one second
move to mate okay check if Magnus is
online what's the count
let me just check well almost
nope no he's not on one nope someone is
and it's better for him yeah otherwise
ah yeah okay it's not okay even one more
game and then I'm just gonna do the
giveaway yeah did you get the new
Pokemon game no I I don't even know
which Pokemon game is new the last
Pokemon game I play was on Gameboy was
like pokemon yellow who would be big
fish or top they'd pick for one with
better player no one
again it's give this Bishop on d3 Bishop
it on d3 is not good
that's a pawn cutting off the connection
between the Queen and the Knights
what he was reading evil what you're
reading what not reading it was 1800 but
I found down button leeches 1,400 let's
do too much too much brawl stars I would
say he knows that the Queen belongs on
c7 okay what to do what to do there is
one rule about tactics we know your
opponent offers you submission you
should take it so now he has to fight
okay
yeah but what else is there
there is one move
there is one defensive move I'm not
going to tell you but there is one need
a sneaky move sneaky move very evil
defense like now you have him you you
have him yeah they say push d4 I pushed
d5 but it's okay it's a good position oh
it's not so bad haha yeah c4 who do I
think will win the candidates well we
only know four player who are in the
candidates at the moment so it's hard to
say who who win no 5 now with the Grisha
well Grisha almost being now a candidate
so we still have to wait and see for the
final final tournament do I read private
messages on leeches
yes I do I do read them but very rarely
like I will read them tomorrow chance
and all the winners of the tournament
will send me messages regarding
regarding the prizes ok
[Music]
everyone is asking what is Evo's Evo Evo
is doing so good okay can you check me
no no you don't have to meet you just
have to flag him oh just free movie yeah
okay good draw good draw that is a good
draw okay let's let's just take care of
the giveaway all right so the giveaway
this time the website we'll be using is
the same website we've been using for
every giveaway it's the YouTube random
commenter so here we've we just copy
paste the link from the from the video
that we're gonna be using for the
giveaway we paste we paste it here so
I'm just gonna refresh everything so you
see that everything is happening from
the start and let me just wait there's a
30 second delay there's a 30 second
delay and I have to bring up I have to
bring up the other display yep this one
will do okay so here we're just gonna
paste the video here there you have it
and we're gonna filter duplicate users
so hope you can you guys can see that
here it says UK filter duplicate users
and filter comments based on a specific
text and we're gonna write in hashtag at
all which is what you guys had to ride
in to enter the giveaway here we have it
get YouTube comments we're gonna do that
so here it's just gonna gather up
comments to see how many of you and
these are only unique comments so some
of you commented like hundred times it
will only take one of them so there are
let's see 1400
okay thirteen hundred and eighty unique
comments and here what's this this is no
tense situation yeah start raffle and
pick random winner okay we're just gonna
fire up our mighty notepad
all right there we go - right in the
winners gu right here stick dollar yeah
okay here we go
start raffle and pick random winner
there we go
so okay first we're going to pick the
nine winners of the $25 Amazon gift card
then the one winner of the $250 gift
card so it's drop a loose
he says hashtag tile is the greatest
that is a good name that is a good name
and also a good message so repels first
prize is drop a loose okay
second prize and here yes
congratulations to the repels and here
we have picked another winner this is
the one thing that we didn't have the
previous time previous time we had to
wait longer but now we just pick another
winner so everything is everything is
working nicely now it's max Henderson
max Anderson said I feel bad for Jack
Miller such a brilliant player yet so
little known about him he nearly had
tall here yes he nearly a tall tall here
and I've received some messages on my
email regarding mr. Jack Miller who was
his tutor and that he was really really
an impressive player that he was able to
beat international masters but then
again he lost the games to like 1600
players so something something like
rashidun news Medina you would say okay
sorry
drop fellas here max Henderson without
this alright let's go for a third winner
[Music]
alright third winner is Juan Ilya many
of my games are lost or won because I
always keep searching for tall moves
that is well you know nicely-nicely said
that deserves to be on the first place
yeah but it's it's a random its but yeah
that is very nicely set alright let's
see forth the winner of the $25 Amazon
gift card goes to get woo he says tall
is a Latvian legend that is correct mr.
Gao you are going into the mighty
Notepad there we go
[Music]
picking and not
winner let's see start they all have
really cool names yeah
the winners yeah Moctar al I'm sorry
he says tal has become the symbol of
excitement in chess he never disappoints
when you seek a good game that is very
well said mr. Moctar
al ansari you also go into the mighty
node fad there you go
great pick another winner all right
there we have Iman SIOC there are two
types of sacrifices correct ones and
mine very well said mr. Iman you also go
into the notepad there we go that will
sex loot yeah pick another one four more
to go
three more plus the the main prize
winner main prize then Sam Tobin says I
usually prefer more recent games but
there is nothing better than such a
brilliant seat by Michael Tao I think
he's German yeah some sleep some cleave
you think so yeah Suntory you think is
German yeah some clip simply okay
Benz I'm Clavin if you are German you go
into the note pad being German yeah for
jawline it's always exciting to see fate
hash tactile moves okay that will work
that will work that's also nice you also
go into the notepad there we go
international that's I believe that's
eight so two more second to last who
takes who takes this one it's CGG see
one three eight nine in the spirit of
Michael Tao
alright you also go into the notepad and
now for the final winner there we're
gonna drop to two enters here to make it
more official pick another winner okay
good luck to everyone this is it who
gets you know 250 dollars to get the Bob
if you
action figure did you participate okay
oh that would be super weird BS chaos
chaos chaos chaos probably Mexican I
thought the game would be the game which
tall one in aa national versus tall so
we want that game soon yes the fourth
game between Nash Medina and tall we
will show that game but not very soon
since it's the only game between tall
and as MIDI know that we haven't shown
ok
you go into the mighty notepad and we
will save it here as winners there you
go
ok I accidentally wrote sinners but it's
actually winners that will do nicely
yeah it's not sinners its winners
alright so here we have go back here and
there we go
back the leeches alright so that's it
with the giveaway near sinners yeah
that's fortunate
yeah but the W is like right above s and
you know I tried to type fast and you
know it went wrong but yeah you guys are
the winners and tomorrow I will go
through all of them so contact me via
email all of the emails are available in
every one of my videos so it's a good
matter at gmail.com also have a matter
manga at gmail.com and also you can just
contact me via Twitter or Facebook I
will I will check it out so that being
said we will now continue to accept
challenges okay I'm just gonna accept
one then if you want yours out of you
want one yeah of course okay so let's
find a nice ok an ice bullet one not too
many bullet games people are not too
crazy about bullets okay yeah Hodder is
thank you very much for for helping us
out being in the mod you know the good
stuff good stuff sir and have a good one
freeze no it's not freeze it's just
there's just a delay okay okay so what
okay
so maybe maybe we do have some lag but I
don't think so it's the picture yeah I
think it's it will switch okay okay
we're gonna refresh this pick a new
model please okay we will pick a new
mode no problem
he's too harsh
how can he be too harsh he has the you
know worry about about such things b5
was very interesting probably was very
interesting years yeah the F files okay
how about we push this okay blocking but
now we go now we go here okay he wants
to go Queen h4 we're not gonna allow
that
okay we're too slow we need to pick up
the pace okay you can play that that's
interesting huh okay
no we have a good position with the
bishop here that's that was a lousy move
okay Wow okay
it definitely starts pre moving now it's
too much too much of a pre move i I
guess okay good that was that was a bit
lame but it's okay yeah okay you have to
you have to do it at some point okay let
me just see if okay we still haven't
received any messages from the winners
so I guess they will contact us tomorrow
yeah they're busy playing the
the titled arena yeah okay you want to
play a few should I stay here out there
which you do want here okay you want the
bat I want the bad chair yeah so okay
I'm gonna accept to human except for
zero woman okay I'm gonna play this
schedule 1 plus oh okay well it doesn't
matter
okay two point two point zero it's okay
okay it's just a new account
should I play Queen sacrifice or not yes
okay okay
soon as possible we have a so big I'm
not used to this mouse but okay oh yeah
it doesn't matter if you send me fake
fake ones claiming that you want to give
away because you have to use the same
account that the Queens gambit declined
so it's it's not a problem if you if you
try and fake it Ronaldinho is having
some pizza in the kitchen yeah he really
loves the pizza yeah
okay I have this attack on the default
if something happens should go be three
or D 3 okay I don't think we need an
additional mod but I'm gonna go h4 h4 is
now important you'll see why because
he's gonna in one particular move he's
gonna go g6 and because I need this age
for why did I stop smoking yeah
okay this was fast I think I just smoked
too much and then just you know stopped
being stopped being interesting I guess
we have here okay I'm gonna play dim
voyage dig where to zero okay if it's
the strong player to top already if you
can you play the Evans gambit okay I'm
not familiar with black which black yeah
okay I'm gonna get going my ID okay in
my favorite line my dragon Sicilian
setup
yeah you think smoking is bad for you
you know this is probably not so good
before all right yeah I have some
material here if you want to challenge
just go to Lee chess and you know click
on click another matter you I guess it's
right click you know challenge drop a
challenge
okay now a four is the idea to deflect
no pure a traverses are onion
you mean from the from the top of steel
yeah this is some dangerous [ __ ] going
on how to increase the probability of
challenge getting accepted well first
you have to have a really cool name like
like here mr. dim booyah
yes well she has a brutal brutal name
this is so no that helps also not
challenging to a 5 + o or me action plus
3 okay I'm gonna take the rook pool okay
should affect the Queen let's sec the
Queen somehow no I want to check the
Queen somehow but not not yet not yet
well you could pretty much do anything
here now I'm gonna check the Queen now
it's time I can no thank you
capture the night yes capture the night
and then rookie yeah but I want to SEC
the Queen I promise that I'm going to
sack the Queen has anything
so he has to knock back rank Pro ha Oh
same Shh
same [ __ ] different day okay we're gonna
accept another challenge so then I'm
gonna let my nephews playing I'm gonna
play just another one and we have Peter
Peter Peter already played oh no oh no
how did you how did you pick I don't
know Peter is really okay good Peter how
the challenge in mobile I have no idea
plays the role he plays the peroxy Biman
barack see ya american same Roxie but he
was a guest on my route see ya they say
also use our oh yeah okay I would know
how many challenges currently there are
a hundred and thirty challenges awesome
fish for random games to know that would
be interesting that would be cool that
would be very interesting so I'm gonna
go for this trade of Bishop no I don't
think that's viddler I don't think
that's Euler so please play rook on do
you want very good yeah Peter Peter got
another game Ian Peter speeders top guy
squeeze one in okay here here we gonna
go f5 yeah sauron there are no in order
challenges unfortunately I don't know
why all the websites don't implement
this like you know since there are there
are like thousands of streamers now so
so you would read some tactics here I
mean course you didn't
of course I have Bishop on d4 but that's
that's not what I want that's not fun
Queen on it before g3 Bishop takes H
takes Queen takes he
this I have opened let's try this one
it's not a problem
let's try this one yeah f4 okay I'm
gonna go f4 let's go for this no let's
go for this so I'm gonna take I'm gonna
check the rook even here again no first
check check check check mr. mr. Emerson
can I share more Bruno is asking can I
share more info about the writer for
chess manga no since we are at the
moment only looking for a writer and
I've seen a lot of you have sent me
emails but we will we will start reading
them tomorrow or more maybe on Monday
and then we will everyone who wrote well
any kind of our reply we're gonna reply
back and try and try and get something
going on thank you thank you for asking
Bruno yes I messed this one up yeah
because you didn't want to play Bishop
g5 before yeah before yeah it's a 25 I
didn't want to do that because it would
be a job - it wouldn't be interesting
I'm gonna just try to wake in the dark
first that's my only option now and I'm
gonna promote the [ __ ] out of it yeah
yes someday Magnus might play the
tournament if it's you know convenient
for him he doesn't need the money so he
he can play whatever whatever tournament
he wants that's this is the best way to
play the tournament
okay I'm gonna resign this one okay okay
hopefully it's not a rated one no no all
right I'm going okay do you want to sit
there or the good chair the good chair
okay all right I'm gonna read read some
comments and drink not beer yes
chess is the best that is that is true a
lot from Libya thank you sir Lucca
stitch not at the moment as we are
accepting challenges as they go but if
you challenge and you have a really cool
name then we are definitely closer to
being accepted what okay like the name
of the of the username no it's not Peter
again that would be weird if it was
Peter okay don't choose Peter I play but
it's it's a friendly boat it's a I don't
think it's a very strong but it's but it
might be a strong boat we'll see let's
see how you do against the boat ah
that's good that's how fish were plated
yeah remember all right
have the bishop pair it what he's
playing against the ball not against the
human whoo it's both shadrach it's both
winning both winning yes it's fair since
it's it's against the boat rated so SEC
tonight it's like it's like baby off a 0
so we have ganged up on you get both
he's a fine boy yes he is a very funny
but like he's probably gonna capture the
bishop now
no okay is there me is there a mate hmm
all right yeah that's a rook but maybe
there's also mate or easy
I don't think so just take the ball okay
the boat the boat is defending the boat
is playing oh no no Oh capture it ah and
now the boat is winning what winning
meet her what we need
I hate buh yeah I have no idea how to
how would you do it in an app I very
rarely use apps even take my place for a
second stupid yeah we had winning
position but now we have to struggle I
[Music]
don't have time stupid times take take
this body's strong I'm going to lose to
a boat sometime let's fight against
cooling mm that's why truth yeah
checkmate in value to extra sneaky extra
sneaky castle go for a stalemate go for
the Banco gambit we have the make it is
very aggressive so I played
going for the c-4 weakness thinks you
should you have to take the night
position to do not know what you know to
somehow get the d5 come home d4 d5 is
the manor you I don't think
g65 somehow that's the plan
okay you can trade off the night game
you have an outpost night he fight he
could be quite that that's
okay this is not good this is good you
have a better Bishop yeah
oh man it's okay it's not approach we
can go check and mate why do you a do
want to try something
what Let's Plays I want so let's blue
let's write the two of us playing one
one move you one move me can we do that
yeah okay I want someone to challenge us
for five plus zero
can anyone challenge us five plus zero
casual fine so one one move my nephew
will play then I'm gonna play move five
plus zero please if anyone can challenge
us so go down I hope we have challengers
five plus zero so so you're gonna this
is for it just read okay careful okay
yes yeah yeah but but except you're
gonna play a move then I'm gonna play
who's going to be first you boy first
okay
[Music]
don't OD mouth next way okay okay you're
gonna play now I'm gonna play it my
second move now it's Phillips turd
so it's both of us playing now it's my
turn
I'm gonna go a six so it's not Phillips
traitor
I got his drinking beer there it's my
turd okay he's gonna go some bishop on
h6 motifs I'm gonna go but I can do I
think we can stay even with the King in
the center here at least yeah what to
play
okay I'm gonna cap
ah hello everyone yeah we kidnapped I
got my sauce it's it's not my music it's
now my move I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
with the night switch that also also
works maid is here
our master is in gulag yeah kidnap for
you so yeah they say you shouldn't talk
about the moves between
turns kind of cheating point on it
cheating it's cheating yeah but you only
five minutes how come so we can we can
change but okay it's not a problem
your maja someone says they sent you a
game that you said you would show and
you did not show it which one bad
mysteries are which ones I don't know
someone with which gave it
only pre moves Thank You Dario thank you
very much and thank you for suggesting
all those games on leeches probably
Kings gambit no my favorite even schemes
it's my turn yes whose turn is it okay
okay very good
he has this isolated pawn weakness so
we're gonna go for that so yeah play
blindfold handle brain I think that's
more of a more of a a carving okay we
have elite amount of people watching us
one three three seven what is this again
not to me
ah that is there is the greatest mystery
ever that was mysterious now it's my
turn oh yes okay okay
what is Colonel Dino he's still eating
pizza yes
feels quite a large pizza it's like the
biggest one
we do the shows like well yes but I
I will not really just yet we already
agreed yes sir
yon and myself huh you thought of have
you ever won against Carlsen of course
not I expected but do you like eben no I
don't like get Bonanza I hate that [ __ ]
so yeah that matter means player in
Esperanto but I didn't know that we
don't have such a good position I think
I didn't even know Esperanto sister when
I was formed could you shut out Yosh a
what Yosh ha ha given it's never done
ok guys you were down on time oh it's my
turn ok ok but he's lying
I think your move is now
ok I wanted to ask so why you say the
show word yours out of every two words
you say a lot of sure words it is fine
yeah I don't want to swear on online
[Music]
favorite opening with black my favorite
opening is black not to the French
defense I like I like to accelerate a
drag yeah we have to be fast no it's not
yes you can you can pronounce it
Haven inga or something like that 17:17
buuck what's good gear here yeah it was
not formed randomly no Raj wants to know
where were called in you where is mr.
Dean Ronaldinho's yeah okay but it's it
was my move I forgot we have a game game
going on here
[Music]
[Music]
this is going to be drawn very
interesting no it's not a draw it's
winning
yeah probably Maris or I've done this
part of even Chuck's 1991 but that's 94
I believe huh no it's not a draw
how can be it wrong yeah the b-pawn is
not a draw I see a pond sipping f1 and a
draw
it's a beep on it's a win yeah whenever
he moves the king that is elementary
Phillip in game going oh oh that's not
I'm just in this in this maneuver
maybe we have 17 seconds faster very
nice nice guys
okay are we going to play missing Roger
once wants to see you play walk yes
that's a weird accent where your oh
[Music]
that's too good of a center how did you
get such a good center that's that's
winning for black Thank You mr. Ruben
hurt really bad I was a was a was a
strong boat with the did you win against
the body
oh do I play with about son
which he's a good player or me from the
Raj is the best I still have a positive
score against him but he is very strong
let's play me yeah no I uh Rubinstein
saga also at some point we will cover it
okay meeting Raj was so busy calling for
Colonel Dino he he lost track of this
and we're just gonna check out he
reached
okay we're just gonna check up on the
undelicious titled arena how they are
doing after this game L Zbornak
Al Gore Nick is here he's from Spain
yeah sure look here oh sure sure yeah
chalky definitely one of the one of the
more favorite guys Thank You mr. Daniel
Thank You mr. Daniel you okay Colonel
Dino please a few teams and then we're
gonna check up on the titled arena a bit
more ok so Colonel do you play until
10:00 p.m. and then we switch it to
check on the titled arena oh it is up
okay okay oh it is a 120 penguin 97
thank you okay
[Music]
yes against like a boy
yeah the Backstreet Boys the back ranked
boys
[Music]
yes yes my dear sir do it - are you
going to place strong yes only strong
even what is happening I think I think
he is not aware that the game started
yet
looks like Eminem fan club I don't know
maybe maybe yeah abort if if no moves
are made abort try the new piece set no
we're not gonna we're not gonna spoil it
alright perfect is mr. perfect buy a
good night of a good night you already
wasted five seconds
yes sorry the night the g4 I don't like
the night
allowing black too much why Oh on your
phone no someone said that we should
Google or a matter of dog and it it says
meadow I don't know that's true but or
maybe maybe no maybe if you click images
I guess it's true yeah if you google
matters dog you get a beautiful photo of
meadow we two of them actually two of
them but you have to click images like
unlike if you go to Kevin's bracket
images you know okay that's that's very
old
somebody should haunted ya Dario I don't
well it's not like I don't consider this
a job so that's probably why I do it
without so without much well I wouldn't
say effort but without dwelling too much
on everything yes that was true up until
like season did you started watching
Game of Thrones right yes you are how
far up ahead season three three that's
you should stop right there whoa no
further well it was still good what
someone says that was a terrible move I
don't know if you think about black or
white okay Oh
sneaky one day though the engine boy
will return yeah engines you'll engineer
everything yeah
okay what's here oh I think you are dead
lost one kid lost okay video goes alpha
zero mode again II lick
to improve the game this is the worst
game yes only tick no I still haven't
decided anything on the next big saga
we're still gonna give it a few days and
then we're gonna decide where we're
gonna take it the creations that Oh play
boat again yeah I don't know how oh it's
a new player with a question mark
reading no this guy did not play since
below you can see who played okay you
guys can since I don't show that part
but this is the first time these two
accounts are ever played
yeah it has to be has to be crushing
everyone in the titled arena really yeah
I think though I think two minutes is
just not his temper yeah nicely so
you're welcome
mail is over over 9000 oh there's a 130
penguin and the other guy's a hundred
105 overtaking each other okay
all right we already had that scored on
[Music]
the watch arrow who watches arrow no I
tried I tried it but I don't know it was
a bit too much for me yeah we don't have
any more cans of beer since we didn't
have any beer we only have juice do what
friends well yes it's we started
watching them again for like I don't
know the 20th time it's a really awesome
awesome show young what happened to your
channel well then there are some other
questions a week with that enough
nothing happening still there is it
online
no it's still there but I'm taking a
hiatus both sorts is it is it is it
still called yon almighty Channel
I hope it is if you two didn't change
[Music]
yeah I would like to show some games my
grandfather played although I don't have
any I think I have like do somewhere but
those are like very long games where he
played the French there you go they're
still there okay but still there I don't
think they were actually interested in
what what the channel is doing I think
they were more interested in what you
were doing with the channel oh well I'm
keeping it like casual yeah it is for a
couple of months now you know yeah I
casual stream in there here and there
yeah don't wanna overdo it it's better
to have a dream dream that dream come
true
are there are there chess boards at the
library of course there are chess boards
at the library one game when have you
ever visited the library without a chess
board yeah play against Christian says
that his brother works in one of the
bars and leisure to see and he says that
Krysia Huachuca is very good that is
that is true yeah I hope someday I
conduct a tournament like Tata Steel
yeah you know maybe maybe next year
we'll see how you and everyone will have
three geologically favorite outdoor
games well favorite outdoor games I've
seen a nice game between around England
they play this outdoor in India
yesterday in the streets
that was a heavier outdoor game oh no
does it I don't know any opening theory
where are you searching for players its
if you find an Indian name I accept the
challenge
thank you it's like 2:30 a.m. in India
okay
I don't know yeah so it's very late
they're trying to go to sleep do i watch
coffee chest channel I've seen a few
games a joke there I've seen a few games
there don't play against the Peter
Palmer they have some some nice gifts on
this channel like there's a lot there
are all the dogs on the channel was a
bro the best tournament ever it was the
best discernment ever at the time it was
play the the the appearance of young
Botvinnik which is no just accepts
anyone can't spend so much time choosing
when you win what first move c4 okay
okay next game we can accept a silent
thunder and then we're gonna check up on
the title arena okay here what opening
now you only played before
how do you know what that's an e4 Goren
basically already played the game so
this is just you know him waiting for
the opponent look if there's a silent
thunder you can accept him that he says
it's very late in in India thunder yeah
maybe but we'll never know
[Music]
ah there we go he was sneaky there's not
a ton of error
yeah there are too many too many of them
too many silent people
if there is no such a such a username
just accept it any I guess zero okay
being no we're not playing on leeches
monthly well I guess that's that's
that's an idea Thank You mr. Lou Luca
Libre and enjoy the Pokemon about about
a monthly monthly edition of the arena
we don't find them will you watch The
Witcher when it comes out yes yes I will
definitely what's the minimum
contribution for you to cover a
subscriber game I do not cover
subscriber games at the moment which one
my wife thinks you're boring what should
I tell her to convince her you're cool I
don't know tell her sorry about that
like if you think chess is boring then
there's no helping you I don't know
[Music]
[Music]
China is not good ingest yeah that's
that's a good one China almost had two
other four candidates for for next
year's candidates tournament yeah we
would accept but I mean it's not like
only I missed it everyone missed it I
know that the author Sarah Vaughn was
born in Syria
yes no I don't know that but I did not
know that although maybe maybe I did but
I know he's not like American yes or
about that works pretty much for
everything
no I've never played against any range
he's licking something he's like more
tea watch chess bra yeah sometimes
really but sometimes you know if there's
like like an interesting match or
something
aha so when she here is the intro then
it's ten minutes off it's non disturb do
you watch Ben Feingold very rarely but
sometimes sometimes ben says the show
opening he has like the more you donated
the more you learn do you watch a
Russian chess players where where would
I watch them you pick me your worst
worst player in the history Ben Feingold
made a song yet really I don't know hi
okay I thought he published a song I
think this is the best game today best
game of all the games for me only for me
the worst game now a good game yes there
was a very nice game thank you thank you
okay let's just check up on the tile
arena okay we're gonna leave this here
first let's just check if Berto arena is
fatality titled arena okay all it is is
crushing it like a boss we need to cheer
him up let's let's check a few games by
ali reza waste this guy
thunder thunder thunder
yeah very tough for overall there is at
Lowe's points on the previous one but
seems like this one yeah there is been
playing for four hours straight
I don't watch Dragon Ball I've seen it
so many times
yeah awesome okay for the stream you
have to play one game against him okay
we're gonna check out this will have to
see where he is
thank you mr. Ryan Brooke thank you for
the for the forty praise yes it is a lot
of content but we do enjoy it
very from all right now let's all you
know concentrate and find our island
founder okay we have to we have to find
him let's go
all right no no no try me to lose my
friend yeah he says where I think he's
just trolling us at this point
I literally there's the boat okay
peekaboo Remy to Peter is still here
we're trying to squeeze one more in okay
there's really no silence under my me
too
okay so maybe I need to pick any speak
any and Daddy can the boat don't decline
the boy he will be sad yeah everyone
wants us to play silent thunder but it
will be a nice game a good night of my
friends okay me to drive so let's see it
lets see it happen what have you for me
okay now I wait the move oh no favorite
famous variation
yes sir zoom in the search bar yeah no
problem Devine sheet thank you thank you
for for all the praise all right
yeah control find is it's possible but I
do it the old-fashioned way
what against me yeah yeah thank you
so everyone can see who's better
okay okay okay brother
thank you digital sick thanks thanks for
informing me of that
[Music]
yeah it's not a stressful one it's just
yes the good old the world he he's gonna
even allow that now maybe even if he
takes the Queen take the rook why why'd
you take the rook whose chick I missed a
trick oh I felt Bishop f6 first okay
that's that's nice but the problem is c3
yeah but he just moves me to what I are
doing main I don't believe this I don't
believe this
I believe this happened this is insane
good sacrifice for me
ah yeah too late for me to know where I
hit luck a headlock but you sort of said
he will not play against you anymore
play against oh my goodness okay look
this will be a Grand Prix where are you
brother okay nice shutting down any
accelerated dragon ideas variation okay
he's playing fast but you have c3
okay ah Thank You mr. digital sick but I
did not choose the colors it was a yell
and I chose those they are they're quite
large you know polyansky saga ha that
will be one to promote at some point
definitely is going for it Oh everything
is happening yeah nothing really
happened loud loud speakers Mitchell
versus Magnus rematch yeah we will do
that at some point it's back when in
2014 when the match was played I wasn't
following all that I mean I checked out
the games but I wasn't like following
them at this intensity that I do now so
I do hope to cover them at some point in
detail myself as I am interested in it
Oh time time she says he's eating you
alive
[Music]
oh he sneaked in ok ok ok if you want a
rematch play rematch rematch must be but
that's it then we have to end the stream
yes is very strict about that he don't
want to play is that always be nice no I
have had too many not business for today
[Music]
yeah we don't have anymore
yeah ok I think to remember for the next
one we should definitely grab a mod or
two yeah evil you you will be a mod mod
oh yeah I'm definitely gonna put the
foot up the stream as a video this one
and the one prior to that as the stream
broke at one point so it's gonna be to
shake mate in one don't give me are me
torture you I must give up
it's a spitter alright enough for today
for me good place yeah okay let me just
refresh this okay so basically that's it
for this stream we've been streaming for
a very long time now and thank you all
for joining thank you all for playing in
the arena congratulations to everyone
who who well if you if you've got any
place congratulations for just
participating and making it a bigger
event we had not as much as on the
previous arena but that's because the
tournament broke down five thousand
seven hundred people seven hundred and
thirty two I'm gonna publish all the
winners and well congratulate everyone
on Facebook on Twitter so make sure you
also congratulate everyone because it's
you know the correct thing thing to do
and yeah that's it for this one and I
will try to create more of these events
and have them like at least once a month
but you know we'll see how it goes
so yeah so think guys congratulations
once again for the winners and anyone
else wants to say something
no do you pina all right so that's it
thank you guys and we'll see you
assuming the next one yeah goodbye
everyone